you know showing all those great snow
pictures
and you get the idea hey let's go up to
the mountain
well you have to be very careful that
adequate snow tires or chains or
four-wheel drive are required our
victoria sahab was reporting last night
from just off of the 95 at kyle canyon
and the nevada state police nevada
highway patrol were turning drivers
around you have to have the
the ability to get through up there now
it's not snowing right now but if you
just think you can take your car and
head up there that may not happen you
can get turned around so be very careful
meanwhile on the main road between las
vegas and prompt state highway 160 is
open it was closed for a while yesterday
but there's still some icy spots got to
be careful and hey to our friends up in
nike county on nevada department of
transportation reporting ice still does
have the 95 closed there around beatty
but here in town all we're seeing now is
more folks just getting onto the
roadways as we get the rush hour going
lanes are open have